you can not wear that inside this venue
why can I not wear this inside this
venue why can I not wear
it welcome to Black resin where we
redefine skincare try our squeaky clean
test promise for radiant skin our
exclusive shillig resin formula repairs
exfoliates and hydrates get that
refreshing glow also available as a face
wash elevate your skin care with black
resin your skin deserves the best use
weekly for best results Link in the
description
box so brother Alim went to the KSI
fight and he was wearing a Palestinian
shirt it didn't say Hamas on it it
didn't say his Below in it it said none
of them on it but he was kicked out here
is the footage of what happened we're
going to come back
inshah why can I not wear this inside
ven why can I not wear it what's your
name you got this guy video yeah got
this
your way
okay what you going do he's he's going
to take me out of there he's going to
take me out of there for wearing this
t-shirt so guys as you can see his only
crime was what wearing a Palestinian
flag why did that bother the organizers
why did it bother them I don't
understand I don't know I don't I don't
think KSI or anyone for that matter um
made these regulations or rules why is
it would he have been kicked out if he
was wearing an Israeli flag the state
the terrorist State who is blowing kids
up as we speak into
pieces kids mothers dying being blown up
as they are telling them that there is a
safe way they are telling them that oh
you know we're Humane we tell them we're
going to blow up this area you can leave
okay and as they are leaving on a safe
way to get out from the place that this
terrorist State have stated they are
being bombed as they are driving out
these people these people who deem the
Palestinians as animals are behaving
like animals themselves it is
unbelievable why would brother Alim get
kicked out and now for that matter if
there is anybody where I can buy a
Palestinian shirt please let me know I
will pay for it no problem I'm going to
make sure that those flags are
everywhere and no problem being if it's
criminalized being arrested for it for
what for supporting the killing of
innocent people would I get arrested if
I wear an Israeli shirt no I will not
get arrested it's fine because it
depends cuz two like I can't remember
who said it he said the West is
strategically consistent not morally
morally they are not because it depends
who is dropping these bombs if it's
Israel it's fine America no problem
United Kingdom it's okay if it's Iraq if
it's Palestinians if it is somebody else
without that matter oh no no no no it's
Russia oh no if it's Ukraine it's fine
they decide who should die they decide
who dies as a terrorist they decide who
dies as a innocent person we condemn the
killing of innocent people in our
religion whoever it is done by clearly
Islam clearly prohibits the killing of
innocent men women children and babies
for that matter but for our brother Alim
to wear a simple shirt simple shirt
didn't say Hamas it's just Palestine
Palestine just Freedom free freedom from
Palestine this aparti state and he was
kicked out brother Alim may Allah bless
you inshallah and carry and wearing that
t-shirt and you know what if you can get
in contact with me and tell me where
where you bought that t-shirt cuz I'm
going to make I'm going to make sure
promoting it and you know what brothers
wear that t-shirt wherever you can I
don't care if it is criminalized for
that matter how could they criminalize
something that is supporting the killing
of innocent people now if you don't want
to do it I don't want to support you
guys and get in trouble I myself will be
wearing it inshah in the United Kingdom
and nobody can stop me for that matter
and if I get arrested I get arrested no
problem at all for me I'm not asking you
guys to do it I be wearing because there
is absolutely nothing wrong to support a
group of people who are being oppressed
and we will be besides them whoever they
are for that matter till next
time